la chute du pétrole a entraîné une
baisse quand même notable des prix de
l'essence au pays même si les fortes
variations dans certains marchés en choc
plusieurs impacts numéro un pour les
consommateurs la baisse de l'essence au
québec desjardins a évalué à 2 milliards
de dollars sur une année les économies
engendrées par la baisse des prix pour
les ménages pour les entreprises et pour
l'état et pour l'ensemble des canadiens
les économies serait de 10 milliards de
dollars
on parle d'environ 600 dollars en
moyenne par ménage en principe la baisse
du carburant devrait se répercuter sur
les prix des aliments
c'est possible pour certains aliments
produits ici transportés ici
mais puisque environ 30% des aliments
achetés au canada sont importés la chute
du dollar fait grimper le prix des
aliments selon l'université gwerz fruits
légumes viande vont grimper de 3 5% en
2015 les provinces qui bénéficient de la
baisse de naissance peuvent réduire la
pression fiscale en principe en tout cas
sur les contribuables alors que les
provinces qui sont ébranlés par la chute
du pétrole réfléchissent à des hausses
de taxes ce qui pourrait réduire le
revenu disponible pour les contribuables
et pour les voyageurs si vous allez aux
états unis vous allez devoir payer plus
cher ben oui parce que le pétrole a fait
chuter la valeur du dollar canadien
si vous allez en europe la valeur du
dollar canadien demeure stable autour
des 70 centimes d'euros donc pas
d'impact direct
cela dit les compagnies aériennes
refusent de baisser les prix de leurs
billets affirmant que la demande des
canadiens en billets d'avion demeure
toujours aussi élevé